as hollywood gears up for the 2018
blockbuster season movie studios are
throwing out new trailers left and right
february alone saw new glimpses of
infinity war
deadpool 2 jurassic world fallen kingdom
and so much more
it's hard to keep track of everything
that's worth watching so we rounded up
the best february movie trailers that
are sure to blow you away
oh wow that was unrealistically fast
okay hit it the hurricane heist
the ultimate storm meets the perfect
heist in the hurricane heist
an action extravaganza about a group of
thieves who plan to rob the us treasury
in the middle of a category 5 hurricane
appropriately the scorpions rock you
like a hurricane forms the musical
backdrop to a crazy montage of thievery
and stormy weather
just stay here and let's consider the
word here to be short for here i
am rock you like a hurricane you do as
the scorpions have before you
coming from director rob cohen of xxx
and the fast and the furious
it's bound to be an action-packed ride
look for it on march 9th
the outsider jared leto is in top
form in the trailer for the outsider a
netflix film that will be arriving in
early march
leto plays nick lowell an american
soldier held captive in japan at the end
of world war
ii in exchange for his freedom he has to
join the yakuza
and adopt their way of life no matter
how much blood he has to shed
take a look on march 9th gringo
amazon studios dropped the final trailer
for their dark comedy gringo in february
adding even more excitement to what
already looked like a funny
action-filled tale
representing a u.s medical company a
naive businessman travels to a factory
in mexico to deliver the formula for a
new high-tech cannabis pill
unfortunately he also becomes the target
for a drug cartel
wacky murderous hijinks ensue gringo
stars
david oyalowo joe edgerton and charlize
theron
and premieres on march 9th pacific rim
uprising even though guillermo del toro
isn't returning to helm pacific rim
uprising
the trailer so far at least have us
hoping it'll preserve the magic of the
first film
that is to say it better be mostly about
giant robots duking it out with giant
monsters
that's what i'm talking about with
february's imax trailer it's looking
more and more like the filmmakers behind
pacific rim
uprising understand what made its
predecessor cheesy and wonderful
it's full of useless inspirational
speeches
people shouting and robots with swords
one of the kaiju gets a mechagodzilla
upgrade
this is all good stuff as long as the
movie doesn't try to make us care too
much about stacker sun
consider us pumped check it out on march
23rd
ready player one for a movie that's
mostly going to be a giant game of spot
the nostalgia
ready player 1 is starting to look like
one of the most visually interesting
blockbusters of the year
two trailers for the movie were released
in february the first shows more general
footage
but the second reveals the basic plot
line for those who don't already know it
a voiceover explains that there are
three keys that open
three gates and whoever finds them all
wins a prize
that prize is trillions of dollars left
behind by the creator of the virtual
reality world oasis
and the entire story is about one kid
trying to find all the keys before
anyone else
look for it on march 29th the titan
starring sam worthington is a soldier
selected to become one of the first
humans on titan
saturn's largest moon the titan looks
like a sleek action sci-fi experience
in the trailer we see worthington's
character undergo a genetic experiment
that transforms him into a freaky
white-skinned monster
clearly there were a few unintended side
effects the titan will premiere on
netflix on march 30th
so you won't even have to leave the
house for this one the last movie star
burt reynolds headlines the last movie
star as an aging actor who's been
honored with a lifetime achievement
award
what he doesn't know is that the award
is being presented in a rundown
bar in tennessee let's get you over the
red carpet
[Music]
the experience prompts him to go on a
journey of self-discovery
it looks like an emotional film with one
of the best actors of the generation
and well worth checking out on march
30th a quiet place
after cutting his directing teeth on the
2016 rom-com the hollers
john krasinski is back behind the camera
for a quiet place
a unique twist on the horror genre about
mysterious monsters that hunt down
anyone they can hear krazynski and emily
blunt star as two parents trying to keep
their family safe in this freaky new
world
the trailer doesn't reveal much beyond
the initial setup although we know that
the creatures came in via some kind of
invasion and emily blunt's character is
pregnant which is bound to lead to a
tense childbirth scene
find out on april 6th 10 by 10.
for the true romantics out there there's
nothing like a little kidnapping to get
you in the mood for valentine's
day released on february 13th this
trailer sees luke evans starring as a
man who abducts a woman and locks her in
a padded room in his house
his motives are unclear but the trailer
hints that there may be a deeper
connection between these two people
why are you doing this i think you
already know
10 by 10 looks like a thrilling
psychological study and a welcome change
of pace as we head into blockbuster
season
look for it on april 13th marrowbone
if a horror trailer that isn't jammed
full of jump scare sounds like an
interesting twist
you'll definitely want to check out the
trailer for marrowbone
four recently orphaned children hide out
in their family's abandoned estate to
keep the state from separating them
only to find out that the crumbling
house may actually be haunted
it's the boxcar children crossed with
the shining and it features a fantastic
cast of up-and-coming actors
including stranger things charlie heaton
splits anya taylor joy
and captain fantastic's george mckay
experience all the thrills on april 13th
rampage starring dwayne johnson jeffrey
dean morgan and lots of cgi
rampage is bound to be the year's
biggest movie about giant fighting
monsters that
isn't pacific rim judging by the trailer
it's going to be a pretty faithful
adaptation of the 1986 arcade game plus
bonus material in the form of all the
human characters and the whole
story part at least the three main
characters are all present
george the enormous gorilla lizzy the
godzilla thing
and ralph the radioactive wolf who can
fly if he eats the right toxic sludge
of course the wolf flies rampage will be
tearing up the box office on april 20th
batman ninja dc's cinematic universe may
leave a lot to be desired but the
company has always made solid animated
films
and batman ninja looks like another
amazing entry
a freak energy surge sends batman back
in time to feudal japan
along with a ton of villains including
the joker harley quinn
deathstroke and gorilla grodd batman
will have to stop them from rewriting
history if he wants to save the future
yeah it sounds as awesome as it looks
look for it on streaming sites on april
24th
avengers infinity war at this point
there's no way the hype for infinity war
can get any bigger
but the newly released super bowl
trailer definitely makes a bid to change
that
featuring even more shots of earth's
mightiest heroes and their franchise
pals preparing for war against thatos
the entire trailer is tailor made to
make fans hearts pound
not that we're complaining we'll take
every piece of infinity war footage
marvel wants to give us leading up to
the film's may 4th release
deadpool 2. hands down the most
hilarious trailer from february
is the deadpool neat cable trailer for
deadpool 2.
while it starts out like a typical
teaser it switches gears just a few
seconds in and becomes much more
well deadpool wait no stop
what in the actual ass so wade takes
matters into his own hands and stages
his
own action-packed reveal with cable and
deadpool action figures
after that bit however the trailer picks
up again giving fans their first look at
cable in action
and it's amazing we're also given
glimpses of some of the new mutants
taking on the shadowy dmc
and of course all the familiar faces are
back it'll be hard to top the first
movie but judging by this trailer it
just may happen
on may 18th solo a star wars story
the first teaser trailer for solo a star
wars story was met with mixed reactions
some fans are looking forward to seeing
alden ehrenreich stepping in as a young
han solo
while others were left saying i got a
bad feeling about this
filled with in-jokes from the original
films employing glimpses of everything
from the millennium falcon to donald
glover's lando the trailer is definitely
a treat for the eyes
whether the film itself leaves the same
impression remains to be seen on may
25th
incredibles 2. it's been 14 long years
since the incredibles first hit theaters
so you better believe the release of the
incredibles 2 trailer was an
earth-shattering event
and not just because the underminer is
back fortunately
it looks like it was worth the wait the
trailer focuses on mr incredible staying
home with the kids while elastigirl goes
off on a mission
leading to all the jokes you could ask
for involving a stay-at-home dad with
unruly super powered kids
but i can't keep giving him cookies
jurassic world fallen kingdom while the
first trailer offered a glimpse of
jurassic world fallen kingdom back in
2017
the newly released trailer is bigger
bolder and
more jurassic when a dormant volcano on
jurassic world threatens to erupt
owen and claire head back to the island
to rescue their prehistoric friends
but dinosaurs will be dinosaurs those
silly goops
so they're still set on eating owen and
claire and everybody else made of meat
you need to get us out of here yeah
will the heroic duo be able to save the
dinosaurs before it's too late
and more importantly will saving them
put the rest of the world in danger
we'll find out on june 22nd skyscraper
the only things bigger than dwayne
johnson's biceps are the movies he's
starring in these days
skyscraper marks yet another high octane
blockbuster release for johnson in 2018
and it's filled with enough machine guns
explosions and gravity-defying antics to
get any action fan excited
take the plunge on july 13th mission
impossible
fallout counter to the way most
franchises operate the mission
impossible series just keeps getting
better
this time ethan hunt and his gang of
spies have to deal with some kind of
nuclear threat
and hunt may have to be betrayed again
but where the trailer plays koi on plot
reveals
it revels in its own self-awareness and
glorious stunts
like stealing a helicopter in mid-air
and doing a barrel roll
which for cruz tradition all actually
happened same ol ethan
and that wasn't even the craziest stunt
tom cruise pulled for the movie
i knew i broke it instantly so you're
down now anyone else will go
well that's over now
he just runs away on a broken foot got
to catch those bad guys
superman is literally in the movie and
tom cruise still manages to
out superman him give this madman an
oscar already
venom the internet spent a solid year
champing at the bit for their first
glimpse of tom hardy's venom
and now well we're still waiting despite
not actually showing venom
the film's first trailer does introduce
hardy's character eddie brock
in his human form apparently after an
accident that landed him in the hospital
from there we see a few vague action
scenes and a brief glimpse of something
black and symbiote writhing in a tank
before the trailer takes us back to
hospitalized hardy freaking out while a
few black veins creep up his neck
honestly we could have waited another
month for a better trailer
but this one did the job of wetting our
appetite for the eventual big reveal
which will come right eventually
hopefully before the movie's october 5th
release
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too